have it your way
harry potter is one of the most beloved
book and film series ever made but did
you know that one of the series films
almost didn't make the cut
from directors leaving to political
issues to exceeding the film's budget
and even lead actors contemplating
quitting altogether the fifth
installment of the harry potter
franchise almost didn't happen
harry potter and the order of the
phoenix had a lot of issues during
production starting with its initial
development before directors were even
selected several of the film's leading
actors were considering quitting rupert
grant who played harry's best friend ron
weasley apparently considered leaving
the harry potter franchise wondering
what life would look like if he called
it a day emma watson who played the
third member of the harry potter trio
hermione considered pulling out as well
saying i think i was scared i felt like
i got to a tipping point where i was
like this is kind of forever now she
explained that she felt lonely during
the whole ordeal saying the fame thing
had really hit home in a big way after
the release of the fourth film the
goblet of fire although they considered
leaving the wizarding world of harry
potter both grit and watson ultimately
decided to stay on for the rest of the
series this wasn't the only issue though
the film also had some trouble
attracting serious talent the goblet of
fire director mike newell turned down an
offer to return for the film as well as
jean-pierre janu matthew vaughn mira
nair and guillermo del toro one of the
most creative fantasy writers and
directors of all time this inability to
find a director along with the leading
cast members considering dropping out
almost led to the end of the movie
franchise as we know it however they
were eventually able to find a director
instead of getting a talented and bold
director though the production team
settled on david yates and in my opinion
david yates is a pretty boring director
rather than focusing on the theme of
unity in the face of evil as it was in
the book yates changed the focus of the
film to teen rebellion and the abusive
power he made a very political movie
rather than a continuation of the
character's stories from the goblet of
fire then another issue came up with the
film steve cloves the screenwriter of
the first four harry potter films
decided to not return for the order of
the phoenix instead the team settled on
michael goldenberg as screenwriter who
helped to write the script for 2011's
the green lantern one of the most
infamously bad superhero movies of all
time also john williams famous for his
work on films such as indiana jones star
wars and jurassic park did not return to
score the film instead being replaced by
nicholas hooper the problems didn't stop
there though the casting directors held
a casting call of over 15 000 young
women standing in a line that stretched
over a mile long before finally settling
on ivana lynch for the role of luna
lovegood the team had other casting
issues as well helen mccrory was
initially announced to be playing the
role of bellatrix lestrange but then had
to back out because she revealed that
she was three months pregnant and would
be unable to perform the intense battle
sequences in the ministry of magic they
then re-cast the role to helena bonham
carter which was a great decision and
mccrory was later cast as narcissa
malfoy for the next film one of the
biggest issues the film faced was its
ever increasing budget the film's sets
were some of the most costly and
extravagant out of the entire franchise
the set for the atrium in the ministry
of magic was over 200 feet in length
making it the largest and most expensive
set ever built for the harry potter
series additionally the set in the hall
of prophecies was built entirely
digitally which was very costly to do at
the time filming was also paused several
times so daniel radcliffe and emma
watson could complete their high school
exams which further raised the budget by
the end of filming though they had shot
a hyper expensive 3 hour plus long movie
which was cut down quite a lot to its
final 2 hour and 18 minute run time the
film's budget was reportedly between 150
and 200 million dollars surpassing the
previously largest budget of the other
films in the series in total it was
estimated that the film made around 942
million dollars worldwide making it the
second highest grossing film of 2007
just behind pirates of the caribbean at
world's end it was assumed that warner
bros made a pretty good profit on the
movie but that wasn't the case according
to leaked financial documents the studio
reported a loss of over 167 million
dollars on the film so while the order
of the phoenix adaptation ultimately was
made it seems as if it shouldn't have at
least financially and because of all the
trouble it took to make it happen
although the order of the phoenix was
pretty successful at the box office it
almost wasn't made and without it we
wouldn't have this
you may not like it minister
but you can't deny
dumbledore got style
anyways that's gonna be all for today if
you like what you saw maybe check out
the video on your screen for some
different content i make videos on
basically anything that interests me in
the world of entertainment also don't
forget to like and subscribe as it truly
does help me out and thanks for watching
rocket riley